uh so good afternoon and thanks for
coming and
thanks for inviting me as well to come
over here um my name is dave vasantha as
a break introduced me and i am the
person standing between
you and your evening break so i'll try
to be as brief as possible
so uh so something i've been doing uh
the last few years is i'm quite active
in
in um communicating science or trying at
least to talk about the things i find in
conferences
it's something i found that landed me in
trouble a few times so
these days i try to tell people in
advance i'll be tweeting about the
the meetings i don't think it's
important this time just because we're
streaming the whole thing live but you
know it's time to say
you like this talk you have a twitter
account go on and then it is lucky
that's good too
um so um i think that
my talk is going to be uh somewhat
different from most of the talks
you've been listening to the last couple
of days for a number of reasons
i'm going to give up less mathematically
heavy talk at the same time it's going
to be a lot lighter so that's probably
good at this time of the day
so we've been talking a lot about
genetic mutations driving cancer and
this time we're going to be talking a
bit more about selection and the role of
selection in driving cancer as well
and this is just uh it changed the
background of these slides just to to
signify that it's actually something
i've been using some presentations have
been given
uh before uh all slides actually does
old
they come in black and white so this is
basically something i used to have to
use a lot
when i have to give a talk about cancer
to people who are not necessarily
working in evolution which is
that cancer is is a disease where there
is a heterogeneous population of tumor
cells
things that you're all familiar with
obviously what is this inheritance
so these genetic mutations represent
traits these traits are passed on
and um so basically you have
different copies of the same genes and
there is also important part which is
selection
so not all the mutations all the traits
are equally good at producing fit
individuals
so um the reason i'm bringing this back
today is because selection is is
is not an abstract concept selection is
is something that um
could be represented in terms of
selecting for the theta so it could be
something about how
cells interacting with the environment
how tumor cells
interacting with other tumor cells in a
heterogeneous tumor had tumor cells
interacting with normal cells
had tumor cells interacting with a
physical macro environment are going to
be fitted on other tumor cells and thus
perfect faster dye less and basically
dominate the tumor
and explain the tumor progression so um
if you consider cancer again which
then again is probably not a good idea
but there are some elements of
of parallelism between within games that
team yourselves play and
and real games so if you wanted to to
see which one is going to be
a winner uh you can just take the the
player in isolation you have to see
who this player is going to be
interacting with uh sorry i use this
slide sometimes in europe and
and soccer is slightly more popular over
there i'm pretty
sure we know the rules though so um it
matters who we're interacting with it
matters
why are you playing i asked about this
that you know the
rules of the game obviously because you
might be just playing a completely
different game
so you need to know all these things and
um
if you know that different tumor cells
will be playing
different games with different rules uh
you also have different types of
interactions characterizing
those games for instance uh usually
people assume that the only game that's
going on is that teamwork has competed
with each other and and the ones that
are better competing for the existing
and
ever diminishing resources would be the
victorious ones but there are so other
iterations uh for instance like the
evading the immune system the immune
system can be considered a predator of
the tumor cells
you can talk about parasitism by which
some tumor cells actually take advantage
of the work of other tumor cells that
might actually producing
growth factors or or any genesis and
other things that might actually help
the tumor population as a whole grow
faster
and there is also elements of mutualism
so all these things
all these games are actually played
simultaneously in any growing tumor
of of a sizeable size um
now i'm going to explain a bit about
myself i said before that this is going
to be a less mathematically heavy talk
um there's a whole spectrum of of
scientists out there and
some of you might find yourselves more
in this southern spectrum some of you
might find yourself
slightly more in the side of the
spectrum and department in which i work
which is called integrated mathematical
oncology
interestingly enough a lot of people are
physicists so they are kind of
less pure and more likely to compromise
the beauty of the mathematical models to
get something
that actually might be having a physical
implication
um also when i work mathematically on
oncology once again you
have mathematicians you have uh
biologists you have doctors and i just
want to clarify that compared to other
people i'm
slightly different because i'm a
computer scientist i want to say
computer scientists i don't mean
theoretical computer scientist which
for some people is just one branch of
mathematics i'm a proper computer
scientist
i never looked that pale but there was
it's just yeah yeah never look at that
pill and
i don't think about the hair in the back
that much tend to save it regularly
so one talking about this well i have a
number of models been
based on game theory which i suspect
that that's what rick was
kind of hoping for today but i actually
have a different kind of modeling
approach which is
um i like to call sophisticated other
people might call it complicated
this is is the agent-based model uh kind
of approach uh
where we combine uh discrete elements
with continuous
characterizations the physical
microenvironment so this is what i'm
trying to describe
here and we have used this approach to
study
uh prostate cancer metastasis to the
bone now why is this important
well prostate cancer is the second most
important or most prevalent
type of cancer in males in this country
and in the western societies
um when i met esther science
it becomes it goes from being something
that can be manageable to something that
is is quite
similar to that sentence and when it
does metastasize
90 of the cases you'll find evidence of
this metastasis in the bone
so the bone is is a place where tumor
cells from the prostate tend to go
with with um a great likelihood so um
we try to come with a model of how the
tumor cells from the prostate can
sort of start growing inside inside the
bone and
because i said that this is a slightly
more sophisticated or complicated model
of of
of prostate cancer um we really need to
recruit people who can actually help us
to understand
what goes inside the bone and um i like
to say that this is a really um
good example of integrated research
where um the role of biologists like
conor linz and and
his pastor clear cook and my group have
been working together very closely and
when i say very closely i'm talking
about
uh my postdoc carter whose picture you
see us on stage um
basically talks with leah on a daily
basis she takes a look at the model and
says
paul you know this is something i can
help you with this is something that i
don't think
reflects what we see in the lab you
might want to take another look at the
literature you might want to get some
parameters from these experiments
so there is a very close collaboration
uh to explain
and to sort of um represent the
foundation of this of this
computational model so um the first
thing we did is try to figure out
what is the normal behavior of the bond
so we try to understand
first upon and second how the tumor
cells get into the bone
and start doing what they do um so um
you'll get to to get a lesson of bone
biology by a computer scientist my
apologies
this is this is the trabecular bone um
i'm quite glad that mark rice is not
here mark reister has been doing models
of bomb for long time so he probably
could
tell some of the things i'm telling here
not completely accurate but he since
he's not here and assuming that there's
not a lot of
bombardiers in the audience i'll just
start calling things where i feel like
giving the color so um this blue thing
over here that is uh the bone marrow
this is so trabecular bone terracotta
bone is the spongy bone that you find
inside the bone that's where um
what you find is um the um
the immune cells are born there and and
then released into into the circulation
as you can see over there but basically
what you have is it's a lot of um
nutrients a lot of resources which is
one of the explanations why uh
prostate cancer cells tend to be quite
happy when they get into the bomb
because it's a good place to grow and
there's lots of space and lots of things
that can use to keep growing healthily
if you're a tumor so basically um
the bone is is really dynamic this is
something that i personally didn't know
until i started working with
bombologists but the inside of the bone
is something that is
is full of cells that basically try to
maintain the homostasis of the bone
and they do that by basically having
something called the bone model
unit so basically once in a while
there's a micro fracture it doesn't have
to be anything very serious but
basically
every part of your bone will be
remodeled every every uh
few years so um every once in a while
the osteocytes whereas cells inside the
the cortical part of the bone they
release a signal saying
it's time for me to to to to be replaced
it's time for
this part of the bond to be to be
rebuilt
so basically uh a signal they usually
used to produce
a stop and produce which is what you can
see over here actually have something
like this
so um as a result of that a canopies is
is created
and we will zoom into this canopy um
what you have here is
um a mesenchymal stem cell as this
system cell notices
uh that is an event going on so
basically divides
asymmetrically producing upper cursor
osteoblasts
we find out what the precursor
osteoblasts do but basically they start
dividing
um clonally until they produce enough
substance called rank ligand that
basically recruits these other cells
called precursor osteoclasts precursor
osteoclasts
also come in and basically fuse at some
stage
producing a fully differentiated
osteoclast that looks a bit like the guy
from pacman
but actually quite differently as
multi-nuclei cells
whose only role is is to chew a bone
actually
quite similar to pacman after all um
after a sort of twin bone um they
release factors and
and and substances that are basically
burdens of the bone and these allow
these precursors osteoblasts to keep
dividing even more
and they also produce a gradient and
this gradient is something that this
precursor osteoblasts follow
um and when that protein finishes this
precursor plus differentiating fully
differentiated osteoblasts which are
basically the ones that produce bone
deosto class disappears dies after
producing its function
and these osteoblasts slowly start
building up uh the bone until basically
what you have is a situation like
the one you started but basically with
healthy newly created bone
let me see yes so now that's where we
are
um so we try to produce a model of this
basically what i saw you before is
something that i try to say to some
people who are not necessarily
used to mathematical models before and
they say oh that's actually quite a nice
model i can use one of those but that's
not above this as a diagram
for biologists a model is is a different
thing that for a mathematical modeler
for us we basically try to create first
uh
an idea of of of the real biological
reality we try to approximate with a
mathematical model then we try to figure
out what with the key
cellular species the key cells and the
key um
growth factors and macromental features
that we're going to recreate that might
explain this bone homostasis
we're trying to just create bone
homostasis here we'll not talk about
concentrator but we just try to figure
out how to basically create something
that would allow us to explain
how the bone is is basically maintained
and
we do that via a um hybrid discrete
continuous
automata model basically uh the cells
are agents
they are basically described by
flowcharts and then the micro
environment is described by pdes that we
discretize into into lattice
so um this ms is basically um
this type of cell which basically has a
flowchart you can see here i'm not going
to go into telling to those of course
i'll be more than happy to go through
this
after the talk but i'll just say that uh
for every one of the single cell types
we have a lot flow chart and the
flowchart has been basically motivated
by literature motivated by our
conversations with conor and lia
and later on parameterized by their
experiments and by existing literature
so we do create flowcharts for all
relevant cell types
and we have these pdes that basically
describe how a particular
signals of interest like transforming
graph factor and rank ligand
are used to basically coordinate and
orchestrate all the causes of bone
homostasis
so we basically have something that
captures to some extent
the ecology of of of the bone and when i
say the quality i'm trying to say
basically that
there's a whole thing i mean
so these are pdes for the important
chemicals so all the chemicals we have
modeled here
but then the the cells are modeled
discretely
yes and actually this is discretizing to
integrate so this is just one
one description of of uh of what happens
in the grid but basically we take this
we put in the grid we iterated the
number of times that per times that we
derive the cells
and we let it go when the cells have
some spatial structure or
it's just a grid so it's it's a
serotonin so basically we have
i don't know entirely sure what the
dimensions are but something like 500 by
200
so it's uh every cell represents um
i think it's 20 microns which is
basically the average size for most of
the cells in the bone
and we just basically assume that all
time scale sorry all day all the
special scales correspond to to the
resolution of that grid thought
okay thanks
so we're trying to capture part of the
complex ecosystem of the bone and and
whereas most models that i produced
before most people would basically be
happy with something a lot more simple
than that
we're trying to capture something that
will have enough complexity that
um a diversity of tumor cells come from
the prostate which might have entirely
different phenotypes
might produce a regulatory different
molecules
might interact differently with and
disrupt differently and and thus lead to
different kind of of bone metastases
progressing
so um
what you saw before it's a specific
description of the mobile now this is
just basically
how the model looks like when you play
in the computer so uh
with inside the bones are pink because
why not um
this is the canopy uh this is where most
of the action is going to happen
basically the canopy is something that
is created at the moment that the bone
needs to be rebuilt
you have a mesenchymal stem cell over
here um
that divides and produces this
precautionary sublux which
immediately starts recruiting this
precaution osteoclast
so um recruitment
uh the esto class get together they fuse
they become
this fully differentiated cluster class
that starts to import
you can see the small field of uh
transforming from chromosome
which is one of the factors released as
the two does the bone get chewed
um eventually the osteoglass finish the
job
and the osteoblasts fully differentiate
and rebuild the bone entirely which is
cool because now we can say
in in real time so what real time this
is actually a lot faster than real time
but
you can see also uh the different
screens that show us how these
um different macro mental factors change
over time
and how they basically drive the
interaction between uh
elements of the phone modeling unit so
despite the fact that we're getting
something that looks a lot like
uh what we got from the discussion of
biologists getting this actually is a
lot of work because
between what they observe and and how to
explain
the different basic units uh interact
with each other there's a gap that we
actually have to fill by basically
putting monitor transfer into
experiments and trying
a number of schemes of um how different
cells react to different signals and how
to use the sickness
and in what time points in order to
explain
something that resembles both homostasis
so now we have that you had to
to figure those out based on what would
give the kind of right
picture in the simulation or big data
that the biologist
told you so we we have to constrain uh
the model to what is observed and
in terms of the overall behavior which
is bone homostasis which is
one in which uh certain time scales are
involved certain
dimensions consume but also on what we
know that these cells do
in terms of production of these growth
factors production of
proliferation rates and the normal
circumstances so
we do have control over how cells behave
and we hope that the interactions of the
cells by these these
rules and these macrometal factors
parameterization literature and
parameters by experiments we yield
uh the the microlight macros um sorry
the
the the phenomena that we're trying to
model over here
so um there is there's a number of
things from which we have
very specific data and very very
concrete knowledge and so on things in
which
there is conflicting reports and
basically we have to pick the ones
whose result after you input them into
the way you parameterize the model
yields the result actually experiment is
fine experimentally
we just basically doing the best we come
with this but obviously um for some
other things this very solid data
unfortunately
uh you you really have to try to to to
work hard and see
well you know you're saying that this is
what assault does and a lot of reports
says that they do the opposite so which
one makes more sense you try both
and the one actually leads to bone
homostasis is is
logically or or more probably going to
be the right mechanism
is this relevant to what happens after a
bone is broken
and it's healed or well this place
i i i don't think that's what we try to
model uh
but this is this is macro fractures i i
do imagine that
for so i know for instance an accident
is something i just learned
last friday talking with william that
there is a number of stem cells in some
both sides of of the femoral for
instance and those bone cells are
usually involved
in in development but they also might be
called upon to act when there is a
proper fracture
whereas this is just macro fracture this
is where and that bones
go through even you don't nothing
special so um
no the mechanism in terms of a fracture
yeah 90 days is probably a little slow
yes yes you need something faster than
that
you you have a whole wound healing
mechanism you have macrophages you have
a number of cells that you wouldn't
necessarily expect to be part of the
bone modeling unit
so what the receiver model in this is
because there is this
this idea that um when when a prostate
cancer cell goes to the bone
they basically might remain in questions
for a long time
waiting for one of those events to come
in because this interaction between the
cells
in order to recreate bone is actually
one in which loss of factors
that could be copper by the tumor are
released and could be used for the tumor
to grow faster
sorry sorry i got lost are the the
interactions between the cells
were what you were describing with the
flow
so um the front just describe um
basically how how the life cycle of the
cell but the life cycle of cellular
involves the the secretion and breathing
of of
growth factor signals from the macro
environment so the way that cells
interact is physically
so if as alice in my neighborhood then
obviously i'm going to detect that and
it's going to affect the way i behave
but
secreting factors also modifying the
behavior of of
cells are not necessarily in my
immediate neighborhood
so now we have this the next step is uh
well parameterization obviously as i
said before
um sorry i just forgot to to include the
work of
collaborators which involves as well to
explain to us uh for instance
how transforming growth factor which is
one of the signals we muscle is is
particularly uh
highly active in in prostate cancer
tumor metastasis which something that
i really trust because we're working
with other um prostate cancer
specialists
in vanderbilt and and they have very
similar data for for primary prostates
to make sense
we also know that the the energies are
resident usually in the bone but also
can be recruited by the
vita secreted by tumor cells we know
that osteoblasts also can be recruited
by the beta
produced by tumor cells so basically um
we have
enough data and enough ideas a
hypothesis to to basically uh
produce our own prostate cancer cell and
see what happens
so what happens if we actually put a
prostate cancer cell here but we change
the ecosystem
so we have an ecosystem that is
basically designed to basically
uh lead to homostasis cells interact
with each other in such a way that the
result is everyone is happy but tumor
cells come in and all of a sudden
they basically crop the behavior of some
of these cells potentially
to the benefit of some of these cells in
the short time so they
you could characterize some of these
interactions as mutualistic
in in a very short time frame because
they stimulate the proliferation of
certain cell types that are normal cells
just doing their work
um so this is
one example of what happens when you put
a single
prostate cancer cell inside the um the
canopy
at the beginning it doesn't look very
different from normal one remoteling but
basically
they started uh cropped in some of the
td beta produced by
by um the osteoclast basically um
chewing at the bone they started
creating mesochemic stem cells
due to this tb that they secrete
themselves which basically leads to more
osteoclasts more osteoblasts
and basically uh that disrupts the
balance
of communication between the different
elements that make the bone model unit
such that you lead to something like
this
now obviously uh there's a point in time
which these simulations stop being
interesting because there's binary
conditions that you might want to take
into account
and you see effects like those that
potentially are not necessarily
realistic
but this is a very dynamical model that
we use to basically guide
the experiments of our experimental
collaborators um
now and i'm trying to say that the model
is right because look at that
one picture another picture and they
look quite similar that's just basically
one element of the validation
we use a number of things including of
course the the morphology of the bond
the pathological bond created by
by uh the simulated tumors versus the
one in the mouse models that we've been
using to validate this
then as experimentally you probably have
access to either uh
just one data point or a few data points
whereas we have basically
the whole array of of dynamism that goes
inside the bone in a tumor
so inside the bone when there's a tumor
growing in it so um
cancer cells uh obviously as i said
before when you reach
degree of saturation then in the model i
i just
introduced to you guys there's this
periodic boundary conditions you might
want to take
into account before you reach too many
conclusions but basically what we find
is that uh
the the oscillations in in some of these
cell types is something that we have
that sort of
are matched by by some of the points
from
the mouse models being used so and we
haven't found evidence that points to
the model being bronze so so far we can
begin to trust a bit of resource of the
model
uh i'm afraid that no one is managing my
time but i have my own cards here so it
should be fine
so it pleases you you know i like to be
my own jets and jerry
um so so one of the things that
we did as well is like well we know very
well what happens inside the bone in
terms of we can't really explore
everything because there's not a lot of
heterogeneity in terms of how the cells
in the bone molecular unit behave
the normal cells they usually behave in
a given way if you have enough mice
you basically find a consistent result
every single time with tumor cells it's
a bit
uh different because you start with a
very small population sorry stochastic
effects
that might explain um how the tumor
progresses and actually one of the
interesting things we found is that the
same
tumor cell phenotype in a similar space
of time
sorry in a similar point of space and
time will behave differently and in many
cases the tumor cell
appears and it doesn't grow into
metastasis that is successful and
sometimes
the same similar phenotype similar
location
deals a significant tumor so there is so
cause the effects that i haven't
explored fully but
uh i think is is one of the steps we're
trying to work on right now
trying to convince my apostol to go down
the direction he's really in love with
the use of therapists though which is
one of the things we did okay
so you have this model you believe uh is
it's been validated by by the
biological evidence you got and we have
some treatments in the clinic that we're
trying to figure out why is it that
they look good in in in theory but they
are not really very effective in
practice
so um we have biphosphonates basically
which are toxic to the osteoclasts
and we have antiviral ligands which are
the drugs that basically disrupt
the recruitment of of this uh precursor
osteoclast
and thus basically uh sort of stop the
process of bomb
destruction in its drugs stopping the
tumor itself
um so these are two typical drugs used
in the clinic
regularly and they deal some results
sometimes but usually they are not very
effective
so um this is a tumor cell simulation
without anything going on
this is what happens when you apply the
biphosphonate and you can see how um
basically days uh if i could see the
movie you see that
the tumor goes down some states but then
just goes up again because
it doesn't really have enough impact to
basically change the dynamics of the
tumor
the anti-drug line on the other hand the
one that basically stops the recruitment
roster class
works beautifully unless you actually
assume that
you can reach every part of the main
which is probably what happens in the
clinic because delivery issues
and then basically you find that most of
these drugs really uh work
only when would you assume unrealistic
dosages
and um
basically um what we found is that
android gland
is something that could work by
phosphonates wouldn't work regardless of
how you used an antiviral and we used
woodwork if you actually find a
deliberate mechanism that's more
efficient than the ones
that being used in the clinic so far
now the model actually talks a lot about
t beta and
this is something that we've been
exploring in in different models as well
and what we find is that t beta is is
crucial in order to explain how the
different cells the bond mole
interact with each other so why not
target that and that's what we're
working on right now
now the model is going to tell you one
thing but i'll tell you something else
but this model is not starting right now
and this is something which we're
working at this moment is
the tumor basically here is is
completely homogeneous so tumor cells
are the same
and in reality tumor cells are going to
be different and that's an important
part because
any treatment that basically targets
these cells
very efficaciously you'll find that
there's going to be a subset of these
cells that
it can target and thus those are the
cells that for instance might be less
sensitive to
a progression activity those will be
left behind those are going to be
uh basically coming up and taking all
the space that the initial
team of population uh has left for them
so these tan guys are the normal bone
cells
sorry the tan cells at the bottom
the cells at the bottom and day 222
yes the tan guys so so these are
tumor cells over here now the ones that
are
the lightest color i mean okay
so this is this is bone this this is our
steam bone
as i said pink um you may have wiped out
the cancer but the bone has gotten
but that's what they find actually when
you apply a lot of these treatments but
you find this is pathological bonds so
bond
actually has different properties it's
all over the place it doesn't have the
consistency and structure normal one
see that that makes sense another thing
that actually the model found is that's
okay for the patient
well yeah because you have cancer you
probably have to be very careful about
how you sit and and
how you how you jump but uh you don't
have cancer in the bone which is
probably one of the most painful
places to have a cancer you could find
really so it's
it's it's a really good outcome um
interestingly i i'm really um not very
um
i mean the idea of using thrapes in this
particular model is is interesting in
the sense like you have an idea of
how things could potentially behave but
really until we start exploring the role
of tumor heterogeneity
i don't trust that something that works
here is really going to work in reality
so this is now where we're trying to get
out here what i'm trying to get though
is
is the fact that um in many of the
simulations you'll find that the tumor
is actually not the bigger part of the
population
that the tumors basically uh by by
copting the stroma cells
they cope divide by actually stimulating
their own proliferation
because the proliferation of these
thrombosis increases the proliferation
of the normal cells
so if you take the tumor button as a
whole which is basically what makes the
patient suffer
a lot of these cells are not going to be
tumor cells a lot of these cells are
going to be troubled cells
so um every treatment you think of we
have to deal with the fact that
these tumor cells might not only not be
the majority of the burden itself
but also but might be sheltered by some
of these other
stromal cells that are basically being
coveted
so um these interactions are important
um the tumor
is is not just the tumor it's also other
cells
and other molecules that might actually
shelter the tumor
shelter different treatments and and
explain the proliferation
um this is an experiment that we're
doing nonetheless
basically we're trying to get data in
terms of how the different treatments
that could potentially inhibit the beta
might lead to a different uh
superpolation of tumor cells the ones
that actually resist the treatment and
and we can compare the
phenotypes before and after
and also we're trying to use this in the
clinic um as i said before i don't trust
any of these results until we have
hydrogenity but
we're beginning to introduce
heterogeneity and the way we're doing
that is basically by partnering up with
julio paulson
john park shilpa gupta and knowing the
photo just man dylan
so jared's man is a pathologist still
plays an oncologist
john park is an epidemiologist and julio
paulson is the
chief surgeon at moffett so he is the
one that is is getting all these samples
for us
so what we've got is is um polyphony to
basically take
patience tissue from the bone uh
characterized in terms of critical
mutations but
in order to get the heteronic we need
single cell data and we're getting that
and we have an idea of this categories
so we can basically private threshold
models with that and we can begin to use
that
to start thinking how this category
unity and and the regulation
this particular three pathways that
we're standing for could explain
progression and resistance to the
treatments that i usually
use in the moffett clinic so um this is
actually quite exciting the only thing
is obviously when you want to
take the data from the clinic into into
mathematical model the one we produce
is good in terms of matching the biology
with with the model
but it's not really good at matching
clinical data with the model because
clinical data compared to biological
data is a lot more sparse it's a lot
more difficult to get
it's a lot poorer and basically more so
sdk models
will require a lot more assumptions and
thus be a lot weaker but um
we're getting there so we're basically
using a simplification of this model
parameterized with clinical data in
order to predict how treatments
used in the clinic can actually
determine the outcome of
the progression of a given patient
now what do you do with this uh so so we
could do this this
by by actually you know trying to use
the mathematical models to predict
uh clinical outcomes we can use that in
order to guide
better clinical outcomes so basically
instead of just trying to predict
what a normal treatment would do can we
come with better treatments
and this is something this is a picture
from von kaitenbe which is
radiologist moffett he's part of the
mathematical and quality department as
well
and our department but mostly populating
me have been featured recently in
newsweek um
solving cancer you you can cure what you
don't understand
which is basically an apology of
mathematical modern cancer i think it's
quite interesting
uh the only thing is that bob is quite
famous in the medical community as
someone who is advocating not
necessarily for
curing cancer but for controlling cancer
so basically instead of trying to figure
out
how to kill the most tumor cells the
fastest what he's trying to do is
can we basically control the population
of the tumor such that we can keep
treating the patient
because at this moment where you what
we're basically doing very well is
if you assume that this is um invent the
um population of tumor cells start
resistant to particle treatment
and the black ones are regular wild type
uh normal tumor cells
then um the more uh the more aggressive
a treatment is the more it selects uh
for
resistant populations and the more you
end up with a population of timor
celeste basically
you have absolutely nothing to throw at
so that's that's what he's advocating
for
i personally think that we can do even
more than that i think that's a good
step but
i think we could basically engineer the
tumor we can use evolutionary advantage
by basically
trying to figure out how to change the
macro environment and how to change the
interactions between the different
stromal cells with the tumor such way
that it selects for tumor cells
that are easy to treat or they are less
aggressive but
at this stage this is just basically a
long-term kind of idea
so uh let's stop there just say that uh
this mathematical model i presented most
of it
is it's about to be uh releasing cancer
research i believe is
uh this friday and i know because uh
we've been contacted by the american
association for cancer research to
interview
both arturo and lia who are the postdocs
involved in this project
to to talk about how integrated research
can actually change the face of cancer
research
so um i like to say that my postdoc are
true did most of the work
uh but actually in this case both clean
and arturo have been doing
the best value to the work whereas uh
cohort and i have been just taking the
glory and making this case just
present in the work as it was mine so um
thank you very much i like to obviously
acknowledge all the funding for this um
that made this work possible and and
i'll take any questions you have any
unless you want to go directly to the
beer
by the way before anyone leaves
apparently there's some people who left
some kids here are not entirely sure who
they belong to
but uh they might be uh critical for
some of you here
i guess not well only when they start to
drive their car
yeah is it a good catalyst no i'm not
sure i think it's ikea
so i really like i have an affinity for
complex models like this but whenever
i start to make one then someone
complains that i have too many
parameters
and how will you get separate test data
and training data and how we evaluate it
and that would be one of the people
actually complaining about the modulus
complicated on this one it wasn't
because really
if it wasn't because of the hell of her
biologist i'll be really um
concerned about some of the um
assumptions we made or some of the rules
we did
for for the model but basically a lot of
this has been
wally discussed with them so i think i
could afford to be a slightly more uh
take
a few more risks and then in terms of
financially more complexity
now complexity is something that you
have to be very
i'm sure you are as aware as i am that
you have to be very careful about how
much compressed video novel because it
might obscure the picture
more than help uh do anything useful
with it
but in this particular case because what
i'm trying to model is homostasis
and disruption of homostasis by who
knows what kind of of
uh traits this tumor cell would have i i
don't want to bias the outcome by saying
this the mechanism the tumor cells will
try to hide
and and lead to growth i want to leave
it more open so i need to have this
complexity
for the tumor cell to to to be able to
have the freedom to explore different
mechanisms
it could sort of uh co-opt in order to
to grow
so i guess my question is more towards
uh like when you say that okay so now
this this model recapitulates
current behavior i mean it seems like
you you have sort of a process where
you're picking the parameter that
recapitulates behavior and at some point
you're
i mean there's there's a possibility of
overfitting
yes and it would be a mistake if i had
on exactly that luckily i didn't
we really started working from from from
the mobile uh so
we wouldn't necessarily assume how the
outcome would be
until the very end and then we just went
to
a very small subset of parameters for
which we could actually go on our routes
and then took the ones we we thought
might actually explain the results we
were getting but
we really didn't from the beginning say
this is how it has to look and we fit
the model we never fit the mobile until
i think um there is this this this
different distinction in terms of cover
you you guys have paul happening giving
a talk at dukkis on stage i believe
he talks about collaboration we do
calibration but
uh we try to calibrate the list possible
in terms of of
um we don't try to say all this data
let's let's see how the model will have
to be parameterized
to leave these results we want to take
their their experimental data and some
literature data
and see what comes out of it so that is
mostly work we
uh find it so it actually doesn't
deal results that are i'm very
biologically invisible it's it's a
smaller part of the of the whole process
but i don't think you have as many
parameters as paul mcluhan
no no we don't what you have to do your
little
you know flow charts which which sort of
say well okay
if after 14 days i do something and
certainly they're you know there's there
are things in your
chemical equations but though yeah those
are probably pretty
well understood strong from chemistry
you know
but it's just not from from the models
i'm used to use this a lot more
sophisticated in some respects and it
requires you to
have a better understanding of the
underlying biology
so usually at the beginning actually i
have something i was a bit nervous about
it but it turns out to be actually
rather good as long as you have the
right base
you know in some days times you have
good collaborators as well but the
biology is a lot less understood
and even if you have people who are
willing to help they might not have
the understanding it takes stocks to
produce these kind of models but bond
because so you're saying it's well known
the
the parameters that you need are well
established especially when it comes to
the bond modeling unit because this is
studied in cancer but it's also studied
normally so there is a lot of biology
just having bone in normal circumstances
so
we use that information as well and
because they are not tumor cells
with the increasing heterogeneity that
comes with that a lot of the results can
be a lot more predictable and
and reliable than potentially where you
find in a lot of cancer research
but your simulations have a small number
of tumor cells i mean like
15 000 tumor cells
pretty tiny
this bone remodeling is happening sort
of close to the
inside surface of the bone yes yes
well um well so basically a trabecular
bone which is probably modern is is
so maybe that the picture was describing
this
is it could be misdemeanor sometimes
because we're just basically assuming
that
soda is upon
so um we do the whole modeling unit here
but
uh basically it could be in the middle
of space as well in the sense that
there's director bone everywhere and
this 3d structure as well so
you could actually find something there
but
um that's that's the inside
here is what we're trying to remodel not
the regular pawn over here which
has different structure and is less
known to be a place where tumor cells
try to metastasize we're actually
drawing these little boxes inside the
camaro or
uh yeah because there is also a
trabecular bone so
everywhere will you find regular one as
i said this is 3d structures you'll find
that over here you could be in contact
with one of the walls as well
this is the spongy mesh yeah right yeah
yeah
um i guess this is partly a clarifying
question so
so my understanding is that you a lot of
the biology is known about this system
you sort of
chose your parameters to match the
biology but then there's like
certain parameters that are kind of iffy
you just kind of
like it's funny because selection first
yeah um well i don't want to give the
idea that a lot of these parameters were
that did the dear starboy actually was
the small minority of them
but uh there's uh there's a lot of
things the values for instance don't
necessarily measure
there's a lot of things that they don't
find particularly interesting they don't
talk
measurements for the sake of measurement
they take measurements when they can
explain something they couldn't explain
before
so there is a number of things that you
would need in order to parameterize a
mathematical model
that they might have measurements for
but there is going to be some that they
don't because
it's not interesting on its own it's
interesting only as part of an iterative
work so
we caught up close with the solution of
those and then for the small minority
that were not either recording the
pressure or
they could do experiments easily for us
then we would have to basically
fine-tune
some of the existing data in order to so
so did you do any sort of like model
selection like an unbiased search of
like parameter space and just be totally
uh like not have any knowledge at
priority about the system and see which
models like
pre-situate what you would expect to see
the dynamics up there
so basically uh if you imagine that you
have like three different ways you can
go with a particular parameter
uh arturo which is not a bond biologist
this is the mathematical model behind
this model but just basically run
three of them and say well this is what
happens when you basically assume this
this is what happens when you assume
that this is what happens when you see
in this other thing
and and then we just go back to leo or
conor and say well this is what we
assumed
and this is what comes out and they're
going to say well if you send this and
you have to parameters this way
there's something that has never seen
before so this is less likely to be
and this is more likely to be so we use
those of course there's also an element
of
um analysis of stability so there is
so for some parameters you have to make
sure that you try a range of them
because say a range of them have been
reported in literature
and you want to make sure that the model
is still to capitalize these common
thesis
when some of these parameters can vary
so you try all of them and see well you
still get homostasis so that's for your
right
i guess i'm just sort of curious if like
there's like a parameter set that's just
totally weird
but that can still recapitulate the
system on sort of like a macro
yeah if we were and we didn't find any
of that but if we did then i'll say that
that would be an interesting area of
already to explore
itself i think that would raise a
question of why is this weird what would
you consider this where is something
worth investigating further
experimentally
because that might be a funny itself in
terms of the of the model
it could be something like maybe this is
an area of expertise that you guys have
to start
working on right now
other questions thanks david thank you
very
at nine in much morning yeah